bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados todo divorcio es
difícil y prueba de ello son las
constantes peleas entre londres y
bruselas recientemente se han vuelto a
calentar los ánimos esta vez después de
que el gobierno de boris johnson metiera
el dedo en la yaga en uno de los puntos
más sensibles del acuerdo el protocolo
de irlanda del norte que es exactamente
este protocolo porque el gobierno de
boris johnson quiere cambiarlo y que
factores históricos hacen que este tema
sea tan candente cuatro naciones
componen el reino unido- inglaterra
gales y escocia y un cuarto irlanda del
norte este está ubicado en la isla de
irlanda que comparte con la república de
irlanda tras siglos de ocupación
británica en irlanda a principios del
siglo 20 los ciudadanos se emanciparon
en 1922 londres finalmente se dio a la
independencia de irlanda pero decidió
mantener su control en irlanda del norte
e impuso una frontera física entre ambos
territorios en el norte quedó la
población principalmente protestante y a
favor
a la corona británica y en el sur quedó
la mayor parte de los ciudadanos
católicos pero republicanos no obstante
en irlanda del norte quedó también una
minoría católica que clamaba por su
pertenencia al resto de irlanda que fue
marginada y maltratada durante décadas
en los años 60 está población comenzó a
reclamar sus derechos civiles en
protestas que fueron duramente
reprimidas así fue como comenzó un
periodo de tres décadas conocido como de
travels un conflicto armado entre
protestantes y católicos con grupos
armados como el ejército republicano
irlandés o más conocido como ir a esta
frontera física fue escenario de ataques
y atentados y en este periodo murieron
cerca de 3500 personas la mayoría de
ellas civiles y sólo en 1998 el acuerdo
del viernes santo- eliminó la frontera
entre las dos irlandas y dio paso a un
período de estabilidad pero con el break
sheet se redefinieron las fronteras del
bloque comunitario reino unido salió
pero quedó con una frontera terrestre
con el resto de la unión europea lo que
planteaba retos bruselas buscaba a toda
costa proteger su mercado único quería
impedir que los productos británicos
entraran ilegalmente a la unión y para
eso necesitaba una frontera una opción
era restablecer una física con chequeos
aduaneros entre las dos irlandas pero
eso despertaba temores porque podría
resurgir el fantasma del conflicto otra
opción fue la que se negoció en el break
city el llamado protocolo de irlanda del
norte la frontera de los controles
aduaneros y sanitarios se establecerían
de esta forma en el mar de irlanda y
belfast continúa hasta la fecha
obedeciendo las reglas aduaneras de la
unión europea porque genera tantos
problemas este protocolo los productos
británicos se enfrentan trámites que
ralentizan y encarecen el comercio
creando diferencias entre los ciudadanos
de irlanda del norte y los del resto del
reino unido- además el protocolo de
irlanda del norte ha sido rechazado
desde un principio por los unionistas un
poderoso bloque político que defiende
históricamente la unión de irlanda del
norte al resto el territorio británico
temen que esta separación de facto pueda
abrir las puertas a un eventual proceso
independentista y actualmente por ello
tiene bloqueada la formación de un
gobierno en la región que propone el
gobierno de boris johnson
londres ha amenazado con activar el
llamado artículo 16 el mecanismo de
emergencia que permite romper
unilateralmente el protocolo si éste
provoca dificultades económicas graves
pero no estamos allí la normativa
presentada de la cámara de los comunes
busca eliminar buena parte de los
controles aduaneros creando dos canales
para el comercio uno para los productos
con destino a irlanda del norte que
estarían exentos de controles y otro
para los que estén destinados a la unión
europea que sí deberían enfrentar la
aduana otro de los objetivos es eliminar
que sea el tribunal de justicia europeo
el que supervise las acciones
comerciales en la zona pues tras el
break sheet londres rechaza su juris
prudencia pero johnson se encuentra en
una encrucijada muchas empresas
norirlandesas consideran que el
protocolo les brinda más beneficios y
por otro lado bruselas rechaza cualquier
cambio a lo pactado acusa a londres de
querer violar la ley internacional y ya
ha activado procedimientos de infracción
una situación que podría desembocar en
una guerra comercial fue la marea de
ciudadanos y políticos euroescépticos a
favor del brics y de los que llevaron a
boris johnson a convertirse en el
premier del país y ahora éste podría
estar buscando reconquistar a sus bases
johnson quedó sumido en una crisis de
credibilidad tras sobrevivir a una
moción de censura por las fiestas
organizadas en downing street durante
los confinamientos en inglaterra muchos
consideraron que el actual gobierno no
se molestó en respetar las reglas que se
rigieron para el resto de los ciudadanos
y desde bruselas cambiar unilateralmente
el protocolo norirlandés sería visto
como una muestra más del mismo patrón de
comportamiento si les sirve el vídeo
para ver el trasfondo del protocolo de
irlanda del norte los esperamos en otro
episodio de cinco minutos en france 24 y
france24 puntocom